Hi, I'm John Green, this is Crash Course English Literature and THIS is Romeo and Juliet,
written in 1595 or 1596 and often called
the greatest love story of all time.
Which, when you think about it, is a very strange
thing to say about a play that features, like,
one off-stage sex scene
and like seven on-stage fatalities.
I mean, let's quickly review the plot: Boy, Romeo,
goes to a party trying to get over a girl, with whom
he is completely obsessed, but then he meets another girl, Juliet, and becomes obsessed with her.
Their families hate each other, but despite that or possibly because of it they fall madly in love and get married the next day whereupon immediately a family feud breaks out.
No, Thought Bubble, not that kind of family feud.
Yes, that kind. Several people get killed,
including Juliet's cousin, who is offed by Romeo.
And that means Romeo has to flee. Juliet takes
a sleeping potion to avoid another marriage.
And then Romeo comes back, finds her
sleeping, thinks she's dead, kills himself.
And then, she wakes up and kills herself.
And then the families end the feud. Yay.
That we consider this romance says quite
a lot about humans.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green, but they love
each other so much, you know?
It's like his life literally
isn't worth living without her.
Yes, Me from the Past, her being a woman that
he's known for, like, a few hundred...hours.
And yet, every year, thousands of people write to
Juliet care of her hometown of Verona, Italy,
and the citizens of Verona write back.
You, in fact, when you're in college, will go to Verona
and visit all the touristy Romeo and Juliet sites,
and that very night you will be at a Veronese night club and you will meet a girl named Antonia,
and you will believe that you really love her and
that it is the kind of love that can last a lifetime.
I'm gonna hook up with her?
No, at the end of the night,
you lean in to kiss her like...and no.
[Theme Music]
So Shakespeare didn't invent the story of Romeo and Juliet, but he made really important changes to it.
His immediate source material was
a 3,000 line narrative poem called
The Tragicall Historye of Romeus and
Juliet, written by Arthur Brooke in 1562,
which itself borrowed from a tradition of tragic romances dating back at least to Ovid's Metamorphosis.
So Shakespeare obviously changed some
of the names but more importantly, he
introduced a lot of narrative complexity.
I mean, for Brooke, the story of
Romeus and Juliet was a cautionary tale.
He calls them: "A couple of unfortunate lovers,
thralling themselves to unhonest desire,
neglecting the authority and advice of parents
and friends..., attempting  all adventures
of peril for the attaining of their wished lust...
abusing the honourable name of lawful marriage."
So, Brooke's poem is just an ordinary story about naughty teenagers who receive the standard punishment for their naughtiness, which is, of course, death.
And, of course, as you know from
watching contemporary horror movies:
if you're a woman and you wanna live
til the end, you better be a virgin.
But Shakespeare offers a much more
compassionate portrait of Romeo & Juliet
and encourages us to empathize with them.
I mean, Romeo and Juliet are obviously hot for
each other, but they're also kind of polite about it.
I mean, witness the physical distance
between them in their most amorous scene.
I mean, their most amorous on-stage scene.
I mean, obviously, they d-- they do do it.
And they use the kind of sacred metaphors
that etiquette experts in Shakespeare's
day recommended for courtship.
I mean, Romeo calls Juliet a "holy shrine;" and
then Juliet welcomes the flirtation by calling him a
"good pilgrim."
Also, Shakespeare's Juliet is much younger:
She's 16 or 18 in other versions of the story,
but in Shakespeare, she's only 13, and so it's
hard to see her as, like, a dishonest floozy.
I mean, even in a profoundly misogynistic age, it's
hard to see a 13-year-old stab herself and be like,
"Yeah! She got what was coming to her."
So, Shakespeare was also likely influenced by the love poems of Petrarch, who the character Mercutio mentions.
Petrarch's work is much more approving
of intense adoration than Brooke's is.
For instance,
he believed in of love at first sight.
And he had to because all of his poems were written
to a woman he never met, and only saw once.
But then the play also isn't, like, a YOLO endorsement
of following your heart because following your heart
does get Romeo and Juliet dead.
All right, let's go to the Thought Bubble.
So Shakespeare sets the play in Verona, Italy, which isn't a surprise, since the source material sets it there as well,
and also because Shakespeare set most
of his plays away from England.
If you're going to talk about morality and values -- like individuals responsibilities to their own interests versus
their responsibilities to their families and the larger
social order, for instance -- it's much safer to set it in faraway Italy.
Romeo and Juliet is a love story,
but it's also a political story:
The Montagues and Capulets consistently ignore the
proclamations of the Prince of Verona, and arguably
Romeo's biggest hurdle to marrying Juliet is that the Prince exiles him and promises to execute him should
he return to the city. Should you be loyal
first to your own feelings? Or to your family?
Or to your faith? Or to your prince?
These are not just questions of
Will That Hot Girl Go Out With Me; they
are in fact questions that were central to Elizabethan England, and as the critic Northrup Frye pointed out,
whenever Shakespeare wanted to write
about the problems of feuding nobles,
he either set his plays in the distant
past or in a land far, far away.
But when it comes to the actual romance, it's all very hot-blooded and Mediterranean and Catholic.
It's no coincidence that in Protestant England, much of Romeo and Juliet's tragedy is facilitated by a slippery Catholic friar.
The stereotype of Italians as passionate
and impulsive goes back a long way,
to well before Shakespeare, and that
helps explain Romeo and Juliet's actions.
I mean, would English lovers
act like this? Probably not.
They'd be too busy being pale
and avoiding the rain
and eating shepherd's pie and whatnot, but
this is just what those Italians would do.
Thanks, Thought Bubble. Okay, let's turn briefly
to the play's structure.
Romeo and Juliet, you'll be
surprised to learn, is a tragedy.
And Shakespeare's tragedies follow the same
structure first described by Aristotle in the 5th century BCE
Tragedy occurs when a mostly good character or
characters of noble extraction (here, Romeo and Juliet)
make an error (getting married so quickly, ignoring
the family feud) and are brought low (double suicide).
Shakespeare wouldn't have read Aristotle, but he probably would have been familiar with Latin
criticism of the Poetics.
Now I don't want to generalize about Aristotle and I know that he has a vocal group of supporters among
Crash Course commenters, but it is widely known
that Aristotle was 100% wrong 100% of the time.
If you watched our series on World History, for instance,
you'll recall that Aristotle believed that
some people were just naturally slave-ey.
But while this narrative of tragedy that
noble people suffer when they act badly
isn't actually reflected very often in the real
world, it remains a really powerful idea,
both in our fiction and in the
way we imagine the world around us.
And it's a big part of why we're so fascinated when we
see the once-great suffer downfalls, whether it's Lance Armstrong
or Warren G. Harding or Marilyn Monroe or Lindsay Lohan or the entirety of The Jackson family.
But what makes Shakespearean tragedy
so interesting is the complexity
he introduces to that Aristotelian structure. Complexity,
by the way, not seen in the downfall of Lindsay Lohan.
I mean, at least by Elizabethan standards, Romeo
and Juliet both make mistakes, but they're mistakes
born of love, and it is because of their deaths as result of these mistakes that peace and harmony return to the streets of Verona.
So you can read it as a mere Aristotelian tragedy, but
you can also read it as a narrative of tragic sacrifice,
or as a story about love
being worth the price of death.
Oh, it's time for the open letter?
An Open Letter to Star-Crossed Lovers.
But first, let's see what's in
The Secret Compartment today.
Oh, it's Hazel and Augustus, noted star-crossed
lovers from my book, The Fault in Our Stars.
Hi, guys! Uh, I'm gonna leave you in there, but keep it PG.
Dear Star-Crossed Lovers,
You go pretty much all the way back in literature.
You're very helpful for thinking about,
like, fate and free will.
But you're also kind of sexy.
So if you want to think about free will,
but also give people high-quality entertainment,
you are the natural choice, star-crossed lovers.
But I wonder if this constant exploration of star-crossed-lovers-ness also leads to a kind of celebration of it
and whether actual lovers who needn't be
star-crossed try to invent star-crossed-ness.
Yeah, don't do that. It's unhealthy.
For Emily Dickinson's sake, just let yourself be happy.
Best wishes,
John Green
Okay, so let's turn to the actual writing.
Romeo and Juliet has both poetry and prose;
it's pretty easy to tell which is which by
looking at, you know, the line length.
The lines of poetry are shorter and usually conform to the same metric structure, called iambic pentameter.
An iamb is a poetic foot consisting
of a stressed and unstressed syllable.
And not, like, in the anxiety sense, but in the sense
of, you know, putting an emphasis on a syllable.
And pentameter means that
there are five feet in a line.
This sounds very complicated, but it's
actually very easy. Let's try it on the prologue:
Two households, both alike in dignity,
In fair Verona, where we lay our scene,
From ancient grudge break to new mutiny,
Where civil blood makes civil hands unclean.
Now my performance just then would not have
gotten my hired at Shakespeare's theater company.
Ideally, you don't read iambs in that sing-song-y way,
but iambic pentameter pops up all over the place.
John Keats' last will and testament
was a single line of iambic pentameter:
My chest of books divide among my friends.
And much of our conversation
takes places within iambs.
Like, that last sentence for instance.
I mean, this isn't genius stuff.
My two-year-old son regularly
uses iambic pentameter,
like every time he says,
"Daddy, I want to go to Steak N Shake."
Iambic pentameter is a way of reflecting
the natural rhythms of human speech
in English, while also heightening it.
And it's worth paying attention to especially when Shakespeare messes around with the meter,
as in that famous line,
"O Romeo, Romeo! wherefore art thou Romeo?"
That line would be iambic pentameter but something
keeps messing it up -- specifically, Romeo's name.
And it's his name, of course, that is the problem.
Were he not named Romeo Montague, there'd
be no issue, in the line or in the play.
And I know that when we first encounter
Shakespeare, the language can seem difficult.
That's because unlike French or Italian,
English has evolved a lot since the 16th-century.
Also, Shakespeare was constantly using words
in new ways, as in this play, for instance,
when he became the first person ever
to describe a hot girl as an "angel."
But the difficulty and the slowness of the reading
allows you to pay attention to the genius of
Shakespeare's language.
So, I know sometimes it feels more like translation than reading, but if you stick with it, you will find yourself in Shakespeare's world.
Actually, it might help a little to imagine the
plays as they were originally staged
because the Elizabethan playhouse was
very different from theaters of today.
There were a few indoor, private theaters and a
couple more in palaces and at the Inns of Court,
but Shakespeare's company typically
performed in large theaters like the Globe,
partly open to the air and
partly covered by a thatched roof.
Now, I don't know if these thatched roofs inspired Rock
Master Scott and the Dynamic Three to record their hit
song, "The Roof Is on Fire," however the roof was often
on fire, particularly when plays necessitated cannons.
And as there was limited water and firefighting resources, it was sometimes necessary to let the William Faulkner burn.
So, if you had the cash for it, you sat on tiered benches in the galleries with a good view of the stage.
But if you had less money,
you stood in the pit.
And you usually stood there for more than three hours.
These weren't short plays. Well, except for Macbeth.
Ah!
I should have said "the Scottish play."
Romeo and Juliet wasn't performed at the Globe, but
probably at a theater called the Curtain, slightly older,
but otherwise very similar, although
on the good side of the river Thames.
Shakespeare referred to it as
"the Wooden O."
It was rediscovered earlier this year
by archaeologists working in London.
Theaters like the Globe and the Curtain were
dirty, they probably didn't smell very good,
and while cellphones didn't go off in the
middle of plays, they were not quiet places.
Today, you go to the theater and everyone
gets quiet when the lights go down,
but there were no lights.
There also weren't any microphones.
There was nothing to focus attention
on the stage except the play itself,
so people drank and ate and jeered at the
actors if they thought the performances were bad.
So Romeo and Juliet may be an amazing work of poetry, but it also pandered to the popular tastes of the time.
I mean, Renaissance theater wasn't,
like, high art.
So, yes, nobles went to the theater,
but it wasn't considered classy.
I mean, a lot of times people
were literally choosing between
seeing this play and watching a chained
bear try to fight off a bunch of dogs.
So this wasn't highbrow entertainment,
and I hope it doesn't feel highbrow to
you just because of the fancy language.
Shakespeare knew how to navigate
between high and low culture.
He knew how to amuse and entertain us
while also grappling with big questions
about honor and fate and duty
and human frailty.
And the idea that something can be both
fun and smart still resonates today.
I mean, isn't that why you watch
Crash Course? And yes, I went there.
We are of Shakespearean quality.
Next week we'll delve further into
the themes of Romeo and Juliet
and discuss whether it's really love or
lust at the heart of their relationship.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you then.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller. Our script supervisor is Meredith Danko.
The associate producer is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by Alexis Soloski and myself.
And our graphics team
is Thought Bubble.
Every week, instead of cursing,
I use the names of writers I like.
If you'd like to suggest writers,
you can do so in the comments
where you can also ask questions
about today's video
that will be answered by our team
of highly-trained English people.
Thanks for watching Crash Course. And as we say
in my hometown, Don't Forget To Be Awesome.